un bosque de ribera es un área alrededor
de un arroyo que está cubierto de
vegetación el bosque crea una banda de
protección ribereña que protege el agua
de cualquier actividad que suceda cerca
de este vamos a dibujarlo vamos entonces
a poner nuestro arroyo
nuestro arroyo
aquí tiene agua
y nos dice que el bosque de ribera es
toda el área que se encuentra alrededor
y está cubierta de vegetación vamos a
poner nuestro bosque de ribera porque
pensemos que este es nuestro bosque de
ribera es vegetación de un lado y
tendremos también vegetación del otro
lado
supongamos que tienes una granja cerca
del bosque de ribera el bosque inicia a
ese pies del borde de tu granja vamos a
poner entonces nuestra granja aquí
tenemos aquí nuestro sembradíos
y nos dice que el bosque inicia s pies
del borde de la granja este será nuestro
borde de la granja y nos indica que este
bosque inicia a s pies por lo tanto la
distancia sera
de aquí al inicio del bosque s pies
están de acuerdo ahora nos dice que
termina ave pies de distancia de la
misma pondremos la distancia estamos
aquí en el borde de nuestra granja y
terminará aquí
esto nos indica que entonces nuestro
bosque tendrá la siguiente distancia de
aquí
donde tendremos que d
- ese será la distancia de nuestro
bosque de ribera estamos de acuerdo
pensando que esta es la distancia s y
esta es la distancia pero qué sucede si
no estamos tomando como inicio este si
no este
pudimos haberlo pensado al revés están
de acuerdo que tal que ahora el inicio
de nuestro bosque lo consideramos como
este
esto será ese entonces el final de
nuestro bosque será este por lo tanto
tendremos esta distancia como ven lo que
haría que nuestra distancia del bosque
de ribera será este pedacito que tenemos
aquí entonces pensaríamos que ese menos
b va a ser la distancia del bosque de
ribera estamos de acuerdo pero como nos
vamos a asegurar que esta distancia sea
positiva lo que podemos hacer es
entonces tomar el valor absoluto
db - s o el valor absoluto de ese menos
b es decir que esta misma distancia la
vemos en rojo y el magenta debería de
ser igual vamos a poner entonces que el
valor absoluto de b - s será igual al
valor absoluto
s - d
y con eso tendríamos el ancho de nuestro
bosque de ribera de una manera correcta
vamos a hacer otro ejercicio el doctor
hernández es un extraterrestre viajero
del tiempo y tiene un doctorado en el
año de 1999 el doctor hernández está
desayunando en su restaurante favorito
de la ciudad de mexico y se da cuenta
que ha olvidado su sombrero para
recuperar su sombrero viaja de años
donde te es negativo esto es importante
de años y donde te es negativo ya que
representa que ha viajado hacia atrás en
el tiempo que podemos saber sobre la
suma 1999 más te vamos a ver las
opciones que tenemos como respuestas nos
dice que en 1999 más t
es de valor absoluto mayor que 1999 no
es correcto esto dado que t es negativo
nos está diciendo aquí que t es negativo
por lo tanto este sería un número mayor
a t y dado que estamos viajando atrás en
el tiempo pues esto nos indica que no es
posible
vamos al siguiente 1999 de este valor
absoluto menor que 1999 en este caso
esto es correcto dado que éste es
negativo recuerda que estamos yendo
hacia atrás en el tiempo por ejemplo
démosle un valor att va a ser igual a
menos 3 podemos decir que en 1999 master
es igual a 1996 y esto sería correcto ya
que estamos viajando hacia atrás en el
tiempo donde 1996 es 3 años
menor
que el punto de partida que en este caso
es 1999
podemos decir también de otra manera que
en 1996
el valor absoluto de menos tres años
menor
que en 1999 y con esto entonces podemos
irnos a esta respuesta y marcarla como
correcta esta será nuestra respuesta
correcta 1999 master es igual a 1999
bueno ya vimos que no y si tenemos
información suficiente como para
determinar que esta segunda opción es la
respuesta correcta
hagamos una más estás usando un taladro
para perforar un orificio ya que
colocará el poste de una cerca el fondo
de este orificio está en la posición de
menos 2.3 pies respecto al nivel del
suelo y el poste de la cerca tiene una
longitud de 4.7 pies cuál es la
diferencia de altura del poste de la
barda al estar colocado sobre el suelo
respecto a cuando está colocado dentro
del orificio que he perforado vamos a
hacer lo graficó me gusta hacerlo
gráfico es mucho más sencillo vamos a
poner entonces que tengo el pasto de mi
jardín donde voy a poner la cerca
estamos de acuerdo
hago entonces un orificio con un taladro
hacia abajo porque voy a colocar aquí
una
una cerca del poste de una cerca y esto
estará a menos 2.3 pies
respecto del nivel del suelo estamos de
acuerdo si yo voy a colocar un poste de
una barda que tiene una longitud de
4.7 pies al nivel del piso lo podemos
considerar así pues ahora buscaré cuál
es la diferencia de cuando estás sobre
el nivel del suelo y cuando está por
debajo del nivel del suelo vamos a
escribir algo aquí tenemos las
siguientes distancias donde podemos ver
que aquí tenemos 4.7 y aquí tenemos
menos 2.3 estamos de acuerdo si yo
coloco este poste dentro de este
orificio pues entonces la distancia
tendrá una diferencia de 2.3 pies
estamos de acuerdo digamos que de esta
altura máxima que tiene sobre el nivel
del suelo ahora tendrá 2.3 pies de
diferencia al colocarla adentro y con
ello podemos decir que la diferencia de
altura del poste de la barra al estar
colocado sobre el suelo respecto a
cuando está dentro del orificio que
perforado pues sabremos que es igual a
2.3 pies que aquí hemos visto